it's pressure all around it's pressure
every single day it's pressure and
everything they're not doing a national
football league
I look at pressure as an opportunity to
go out there and prove to everybody
that's the type of person the type of
player that I am I think once you really
change what the definition of pressure
is it makes everything a whole lot
easier
I'm von Miller
outside linebacker for the Denver
Broncos and I'm 27 years old the moment
where I found out I want to play in the
National Football League was probably
about the second grade I saw the Dallas
Cowboys playing on TV and I saw my dad
going crazy and I was like what is that
and ever since then fell in love with
playing the National Football League
that's always been my goal is everything
I want to do
you know being a number two pick and you
know you set all these type of standards
for you you know you want to go to the
Pro Bowl you want to do this you want to
do that and as soon as you reach those
goals it automatically creates you know
new goals that number one priority for
me is to be the player that this
organization wants me to be to be the
type of player that I want to be to be
the type of player that my teammates
want me to be and that always keeps me
motivated
[Music]
when I took my AC on my mind said you
know as you can imagine you know
whenever you get any type of injury it's
always dialed in depression but um I was
quickly over that and I was on to the
next phase of my career and that's
bouncing back off ACL surgery a lot of
athletes had done it before and I wanted
to be one of those guys that I've
bounced back from ACL surgery and not
just bounce back in a way where I was
before but bounced back in a way where
I'm even better
I think my cue to success is being
resilient and you know coming back after
injury continually trying to develop
into the type of person the type of
player that my organization wants me to
be that's always been my number one
priority and I think that's what gets me
my success I just try to take it one day
at a time and you know take the
blessings as they come you know I can be
hard sometimes so when it's great you
got to smell the roses while it's great
[Music]